i'm really excited because purple
uh in also cheek color i've noticed has
been trending yeah and in highlight
colors i feel like i kind of think of
purple as like the colorful neutral i
believe in color for any anyone any age
any like skin tone well i think funny
you should say that because i'm joining
us are three generations of women a
grandmother a mother and a granddaughter
that's right it's glinda gina and zoey
all right neon
show us what's first what's what's the
first step we're gonna start with a
little bit of purple eyeliner we have
one from urban decay here and we're
going to create a base so everyone's
going to do the same thing a little bit
of purple eyeliner on the top of the lid
and then we're going to use this little
tiny pencil brush to kind of flick it
out just a little bit to kind of give a
lifted effect to the eye so we can start
by applying it straight on your upper
lash line
i love this tone of purple because that
tone
is something that i think is very
beautiful next to your pupil so once we
have it on the upper lid we can move
into the cat eye but i'll
wait until we get there
and that's where you're gonna take your
pencil brush linda i am liking your
application yes very i do too so take
your pencil brush and you're just going
to flick it out a little bit
it does give a lip just to pull a little
bit of the color out we're not going
crazy we're not doing a crazy cat eye
but this is something i love to do with
pencils
and you can give yourself that lifted
look oh man it's so subtle but so
um yeah
powerful but so much easier than a
liquid liner for example wait glinda
you're not to talk age but
you're 75. i'm 75. yes
[Applause]
with like the a-line hair and the little
kitty cat vest yes i got the personality
you're ready for a purple liner okay um
okay so you're going to show us how to
build on some more color if you want to
sort of
go a little further i mean explain how
we do absolutely can so we'll start with
something super super super simple a
little bit of a two-tone vibe we have a
little bit of a matte kind of terra
cotta e orangey matte shadow underneath
the lash line and we're gonna accentuate
that just a little bit with a little bit
of this gold kind of orangey
cream shadow so we can take that that
pencil brush again
dip into that shadow and then just trace
over
where you have your lower lash line
color
thoughts yeah
well this is something i would never
choose for myself but with the the
orangey the terracotta and putting the
gold
over it i really do like it it it's
different
okay next you're going to show gina um
and gina you're 50. yes now um how
can she add on to that purple eye while
staying in the same kind of
monochromatic color range so we're going
to go with a little bit of a purple
mascara to kind of match the purple
liner but what i love with dark lashes
like we have sort of more brown my
natural hair is black brown and my
lashes sometimes don't show up when i
put like water when i put like a purple
mascara over it so i like to layer a
white mascara underneath as a primer and
some from flower just launched actually
i think i sent you one i got it a few
months ago and it's really good it's
really pigmented and so what i think we
should do is we'll put it over our
lashes create a base a white base and
then we'll layer this purple on top i
love i love white mascara i am obsessed
with it
um
okay so throw the purple so now that
it's dry make sure it does dry because
you do kind of want to you know be
putting the new mascara on to not a wet
base um okay are you doing the purple
over the white house
and this one oh yeah i see you now
yeah so you're putting it on you're
gonna have to really kind of wiggle it
to get it on it looks good i can see the
purple much better
[Applause]
and gina
keep going keep going
gina that that that tone of purple is
really complementary to the beautiful
color of your pupils and i love it how
do you feel pretty i put that on and i'm
like i have eyelashes
all right last we're gonna add color and
sparkle with rhinestones for zoe zoe
you're 22 years old yes
okay
um that's my lucky number i'm really
excited i love the 22. awesome
we're going to do some jewels you can
choose anything you want here like there
are really no rules i know you played
with them a little bit earlier but what
i love to do is take kind of some of
these smaller ones with a
tweezer right here
and you can adorn your eyes with them
zoe is this something that you would
play with in life
i
love it honestly i think if i'm ready to
make a statement when going out with my
friends i would definitely put these
jewels on and
yeah it's super like a fun out to party
look i love it and i love being like
eccentric and showing all the colors of
the rainbow and everything it looks
great it's great well and like think of
gwen stefani in the 90s remember like
she always had that look going on and
she was so fetching
i think it's definitely a statement
piece fetching i know what
bitching she was
i will say
that i think you all look really good
but most importantly how do you feel
glinda
i really like the the color combination
and it it makes me happy
[Music]